hello believe nation how we doin it's an
exciting day I am very close to hitting
five hundred thousand subscribers and I
thought you know what I'm going to do a
live stream a buncha guys whooping on me
with the livestream comments and chat
for the day have been on me to say Evan
you got to do a live stream we've got to
celebrate and I didn't know how would
work out I didn't know if we'd make it
because that I've been in meetings I've
been in calls we've been having live
streams all day didn't want to push
somebody off because because of setting
this up this event up we're live right
is this is this working you guys seen
this it says it is public hopefully
we'll get some people coming in so we're
getting close and I wanted to celebrate
with you guys I'll live with me here
today celebrate the love and I want to
show you guys something I want to show
you guys something that's pretty fun so
let me share my screen how do I share my
screen I'm going to share my screen
share my screen there's my screen so my
friends at socialblade messaged me
earlier today big shout-out to our
friend Evan Carmichael who should hit
500 k subs today watch it happen live
here and included a link so i clicked on
it and we're going to celebrate with
socialblade we are what 27 subscribers
away from hitting 500 k and i thought
let's do a live stream let's see we got
we've been in hangouts I've been in
hangouts all day long guys I know a lot
of you would join me I've been hangouts
and interviews in fun and chaos all day
long we are 27 away from 500k 27 away up
26 away from 500k let's do it I see Jay
rises in the house this should be
exciting let's get it down yes I know
junior eyes you mean to hang us all day
Jay I did this show up on people's feet
where is everybody where's everybody on
the stream what 25 oh no 26 what
happened it's going down so I want to
answer questions I want to build this
thing up Marcelo thanks to the love
welcome aboard we're getting close nope
so how did you find this did you show up
on your feed I put this together super
impromptu so I wondering how you guys
are finding it 25 come on bring it it
down how did you guys find this I want
to know where is it showing up come on
25 25 25 socialblade i've been social
blade is run by a friend of mine Jason
ergo who i'm in a mastermind chat with
once a week on youtube and I've been
tracking it because he shows me the live
data where a lot of times with with
YouTube they don't show you the live
stuff and so it's a great way to be able
to use to track a countdown twice 24
more 24 more jrice I found it because I
was trying to tag your video SEO and it
showed up on the main channel so it
showed up ok let's see you show up on
the main channel oops where we going
let's see show up on the main channel
what do we get pic still 7676 come on 24
24 let's bring it down oh it shows up
here but you didn't get notified maybe I
didn't click notify subscribers that's
not great well whatever whoever's here
with me now boy we just jumped to 22
more 22 more that was awesome i love
that ok come on guys tell your friends
let's get 22 more let's bring it let's
watch it count down the 500k here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do something
special I'm gonna do something special
here's what let me switch it back let me
switch it back let me switch it back get
it on me get it on me get on me stop
screen sharing it's gonna stop screen
share okay guys this is it there's this
book right here right it's my book he's
going to do a soon
she cross 500k we cross 500k the first
comment that I see knows I'm going to do
I'm going to just to make this legit so
everybody has an equal playing field i'm
going to type 500k into the chat i'm
going to type 500k into the chat I got
it right another type of right now I'm
gonna have it ready 500k and type in the
chat the first comment that is after my
500k comment gets this book it's not one
from the boxes okay I got lots over here
it's the official book that has been in
all of my videos you get this book the
one that's sitting on my desk you get
this book I'm going to sign it I'm gonna
leave a message for you love to connect
how to get all that happening but i'm
going to type 500k into chat we got the
rules clear it was the first one after
is going to get a copy of that book sign
so get your typing fingers ready okay
let's get back to the check let's get
back to the sharing the screen here
whatever yet what do we get what do we
get for 999 8020 more come on guys tell
your friends let's get it going J reyez
damn that's a special copy of the
hashtag your one word book yep it's the
official one it's been sitting on the
last this whole time it's the one that's
look let me show it to you guys again
let me show you let me bring it back in
moving it back in there we go look guys
this is my silver play button for having
a hundred thousand subscribers this book
has been sitting next to that button the
whole time whoever gets this book is
going to win some major award next year
you're gonna you're going to celebrate
some glory because you got the book you
gonna read it but it's sitting right
under steve jobs and next to Howard
Schultz and next to me there's a lot
going into this book it's the extra
special one so whoever has the first
comment after we hit 500 k after I write
my thigh
hundred K you guys gonna get the book
okay let's go about your screen or
through yet what do we get whatever yeah
this is I'm so happy that we can
actually track it when we cross the
number 4 9 9 9 8 to 18 more guys 18 more
let's bring it okay who's in the chat
Marcelo Evan please make a video on the
tutoring business tutoring business
marketing strategy the startup so be
very useful to or doing business
marketing strategies as a lot I mean a
lot of the stuff applies Marcelo a lot
of stuff applies you know making
partnerships get into the media standing
for something important 98 for 90 93
come on who is that whose unsubscribing
come on guys let's go what do we got
who's next is next we got seashell new
tool I've tried on YouTube love your
channel I love you too seashell hello
friends Luke burgundy blue alright I
feel like in the notifications getting
out there people are seeing it Mon sewer
main sewer well done thank you for cash
Prakash you left the comment let me show
this let me I like this look look at
this where is it where's / cash for cash
his comment is Prakash I love that look
guys I've got my thing lined up 500k
there it is as soon as we cross 500k how
far away are we as soon as across 500k
whoever has the first comment gets the
signed copy of my book the one has been
sitting on my desk I'm coughing because
I've been doing live streaming all day
long and i'm here with you I have more
interviews tonight but this is it what
do we got what else what else uh-huh ah
Zeno's in the house thank you say no 8
in Alexander Evan Carmichael all right
welcome guys been far with 93 is that up
that's up okay 17 more who's going to
get it McHale hey Evan love you how you
doing I'm doing great McCann Macau Macau
I'm doing great can you tell do I sound
like I'm doing great I'm pumped then
love that I'm here to see this then you
and me we're celebrating history right
here on this channel welcome let a farm
we're coming 16 more come on guys 16
more tell your friends let's get this
going 500k Luke remember me from two to
three days ago with mr. Kelly yes you
asked the question about being a young
entrepreneur and that's it man being
afraid i love it i remember you Luca or
Luke thank you for the question you
asked it like a thousand times you made
an imprint 985 15 more let's go let's go
let's go what else missile almost missed
it you got it Aaden go Evan let's go z
know how excited I'm happy for whoever
wins wins what wins what listen here's
what's going to happen again for those
who just joined once i hit 500 k i'm
going to type this in I'm gonna press
ENTER on this comment 500k the first
person to come after my 500k whoever is
the first thing we could all see it
there's no judgment here we can all see
it the first person who's after me get
this book that's on my desk going to
take this out and I'm going to sign this
finding a pen I'm going to sign this
book tell me your name i'm going to
write anything going to date it is the
one that sits next to my silver play
button under steve jobs sits next to me
and listen to everything all day long
that's the book that you get i'm going
to mail it to you you're going to open
it you're gonna have an amazing 2017 ok
let's get back to the screen first
person that comes up after my 500k
comment ok we're all clear on the rules
let's see i'm moving it back 987 13 more
let's go guys maravilla what do we need
to do the heavy lied just set the rules
you know what you need to do Aidan I'm a
young entrepreneur you helped me start
my company it's doing well I love that
Aaden congratulations I'm glad I could
be a small part in your success bo
you're so amazing you're the reason I
became an entrepreneur and follow my
dreams oh I love that man thank you for
sharing I'm gonna get I'm going to get
I'm looking for a pen looking for a
special sharpie Sharpie pen what else
we're gonna go sharpie pen okay listen
this is a special I'm signing with a
special metallic sylhet let me show you
the pen guys
look at this look at this okay 500k I'm
ready to go special metallic silver
sharpie pen okay this is the only book
that I'm going to sign in silver you
know what if somebody brings a silver
pen to me and asked me to sign a book
and silver I might just say no I don't
know you're going to get the metallic
silver sharpie pen let me test to see
what this looks like on white first you
open this up what does this look like on
the way any piece of paper what are we
at 9 8 7 13 more 13 more 098 was
counting down guys it's counting down
this is excited let me get a piece of
paper get the printer out okay this is
it oh I gotta put it back on Molly hold
on you can't see what's going on yo you
one okay I like it I like the silver
guys look at that look at that look at
that look at its shiny silver matching
my silver play button you're going to be
making tons of silver next year if you
get this book the only book i'm signing
with this silver sharpie pen this one
this one you guys are gonna get it okay
whoever has the first comment does know
what the comment is whoever's the first
comment actually you know what no no no
no I you know what it matters what the
comment is you have to put hashtag
believe that's the new rule whoever
writes hashtag believe as we cross 500k
whoever's right after me the first
hashtag believe after me gets a signed
copy with the silver pen guys I'm
excited let's go back oh how far away
are we I got more interviews today I'm
going to be so jacked out after this to
my next interviews you guys are killing
me let's go what do we got 99 99 guys
let's go come on 11 more 11 more
I'm going to press enter I'm going to
pray that you guys are already doing
hashtag believe hey you got a white man
you gotta wait let's see it's the first
hashtag believe after i press enter okay
9911 more what else ok 990 10 more we
are in the final 10 let's do it let's do
it guys let's do it you guys I want it
so badly for cash I want it so badly
well get ready get here get your finger
ready get on the trigger Lewis what's
the ROI of this channel I don't know man
you tell me you're watching what do you
get from it hopefully a lot what else we
got what else we got 10 more a min ba 99
19 more 9 left we're in the final nine
let's do it guys come on nine more tell
your friends let's get it on ideas with
you I love that entre society ok first
person that puts hashtag believe you got
to smell hey for cash for cash for cash
listen you gotta spell it right ok
misspellings have believed do not count
you have to spell it for a new rule you
have to spell it properly if you want to
win the book ok the personally
autographed with a 992 tersely autograph
book with the silver pen it's important
ok after my 500 k 9 9 28 more 9937 more
guys come on here we go Lewis I've
gotten one hundred and thirty percent
roi I hope that's good man I've gotten I
don't know my art my roi on my content I
love it man you making investment in
yourself it's the best thing you can do
not nine nine nine nine two guys come on
who just unsubscribed who's trolling me
here 992 come on guys let's go bring it
up there we go for cash that's what i
want to see believe look at that that's
that's what I'm talking about that is
what not a 37 more final seven let's do
it come on guys Aiden just excitement we
are counting down I'm so pumped guys I
am so 994
more to go six more to go maybe the
bills getting crazy lag dude I feel bad
for you bro I'm losing my voice I'm so
pumped up I feel like Timmy's going to
come and tell me to be quiet around me
because I'm jacked up this is amazing t
Scott believe T Scotty Scott Haiti Scott
needs the hashtag niche the Hat a be
yourself you need the hashtag I'll come
on guys there we go that's what I'm
talking about 994 has to be hashtag
believe spelled correctly the rules are
very clear okay don't don't go hate and
if you don't get it because you had a
misspelling 995 five more guys five come
on count it down fine Prakash you're
trolling me here you are trolling me
here dude for cash spell it properly
there it is there it is Aidan prosperity
on the horizon Evan you got this
prosperity on the horizon for everybody
that's what's up that is what's up 2017
prosperity for everybody 996 we are four
more away for more away for more away
Louise Louise spell it properly let's go
cr7 messy shut me out I will sub there
you go sub me man I just gave you a
shadow come on 996 let's go for more
Corrine 99 pot guys come on who's doing
this is this Prakash Prakash are you
trolling me here there we go 996 bring
it come on 996 for more Quran hello Evan
welcome wow thank you LA where Smith
hashtag believe I love it we're bringing
it back nine nine seven three more to go
come on let's do it I'm guys guys I'm
getting listen listen let me let me stop
the screen share for a second listen my
fingers are on like I'm on the keyboard
I'm about the type 500k and the first
person with hashtag believe you get the
book autographed with the silver pen
next to the silver button amazing this
is going to happen you next year let's
do it I'm going back to share my screen
I'm going to push it listen as soon as
we hit 500 k i'm pushing the button you
guys got to get ready let's do it let's
do
it share the screen again what do we get
99 not we just Jeff we were we've been
all over the place 996 okay far more
guys you need hashtag believe guys with
the proper spelling hashtag believe
that's it cr7 messy I just like 98 holy
Christ night I need that was cr7 messy
stepping up with two goals i love it cr7
messy let's do it let's do it let's do
it two more come on guys rapping manual
taco being passionate what you do yeah
man is you guys you guys give me the
energy 997 come on come on who was that
who was that Marcelo subscribe with my
wife's account just now 98 98 my fingers
on the mark my fingers are sweating guys
I'm going to I'm rubbing it down on my
shorts so that I my fingers ready i'm
about to hit enter on that 500 k i'm
about like my fingers i'm going to press
enter it's coming oh come on you trolls
let's go let's go i don't i don't
understand what he was saying i'm
talking fast man I'm sorry about that
but I'm pumped I'm Jack the skill 999
let's go bring it bring it two more 99
I'm about the price of guys fingers on I
gave it a final sweat wipe down here
500k let's do it let's do it who's gonna
be first who's gonna win it who's gonna
win it come on one more I'm pressing it
oh man that night I need 998 holy cow
feel like I should be an auctioneer
something here let's do it believe do it
believable another night here it is this
is it guys for real both fingers oh man
somebody is definitely trolling somebody
just wants me to sweat 998 come on come
on 500 k 1 500 k let's go 997 we're
going in the wrong direction guys this
is the wrong direction 996 you guys are
all trolling me now let's go for more
come on guys let's go everybody wants it
everybody's everybody just wants his
session the last longer everybody wants
a session the last longer you just want
me to run out of my voice 996 there it
is 995 Nina's aunt Nina need not come
we're celebrating 500k they keep
trolling me though
we're celebrating 500k we got a hit 500k
lunch yeah this is live they can't see
you but they can hear you six more six
more we were out one more we were at one
more with so close Ben Famer okay guys
tell your friends let's let's beat these
rollers out 9 96 96 hold on hold on
Nina's here we're gonna do a quick we're
gonna do a quick hello from Nina Nina
get in Nina no you got it there there
Nina she's excited okay I get so here's
their hear the rules the person i'm
going to type 500k yeah as soon as i
think i'm going to soon as i hit i'm
pressing the button as soon as i hit it
i'm pressing the button whoever gets
whoever types the first hashtag believe
after gets this book this one oh my
dad's not the box is this one on the
death why not get wit with the silver
pen autograph and customized message
this pen okay okay we're waiting cuz
we're getting close we're getting close
we're getting else I gotta share the
screen nice 99 what are we get nine
eight seven nine eight seven guys 987
let's go hashtag blue gonna need that 89
88 people seen hi Nina hashtag believe
998 999 look both fingers are on D on
the return both fingers both fingers are
on the return button they're both of you
I might press it early I hope I don't
come on 500k let's go who's it going to
be I'm pressing the guys let's go five
what all you chillers like I need come
on let's go guys who is it Nicholas
makato Nicholas McMahon to is the winner
Nicholas mo photo right there Nicholas
Moffat oh oh it's going so fast Nicholas
Moffat Oh nicholas nicholas Nicholas you
guys are awesome Nicholas Moffat oh dude
Nicholas you gotta swear you Nicholas
you got to tell me what am I writing
Nicholas where are you nicholas Nicholas
can I message Nicholas from this
Nicholas one Nicholas Moffat Oh Nicholas
Moffat oh look I got it I'll show
everybody again man just just to make
sure there's no horth look this this is
official right there where's my screen
capture I got to take a screen capture
BTW robin said I feel bad I feel bad
that was close but Nicholas moffat o
takes it home Nicholas you got a message
me man everything's getting lost here
tons of comments there it is there's a
happy face there's two have you faced
with Nicholas love it oh hey hey hey
let's be nice cr7 messy let's be nice
Nicholas m'fine so I pronounce that okay
sent okay let's let's let's put this
back what is okay okay Nicholas send me
a message send me a message tell me tell
me your story dude i'm going to i'm
going to give you this copy of the book
sign with the pen you know look it look
you look up big your face looks here in
the front there yeah guys 500k that was
intense i lost my voice I have more
interviews tonight this is crazy really
what time nicolas is in geneva
switzerland so time zone is a bit late I
appreciate the hustle Nicholas we're
going to get this off to you send me an
email uh send me a private message on
YouTube whatever we have to figure this
out this book I have to get a new book
up here this book is gone it's gone
Nicholas owns the book guys 500k this
has been amazing I appreciate the love
of support I'm so glad we're able to do
you know I don't celebrate a lot for
this stuff but the I enjoyed my heart's
phrase I enjoyed this my fingers are so
sweaty put looks like this ready to go
appreciate the love guys now we gotta
hit Emilian listen a million is the real
goal this is just a baby go let's get a
million together I appreciate the love
gimme gimme your out your thoughts
suggestions how to get better and that's
it thank you for all you guys they you
know J reyez medival Tamra who were
pushing me to do this live stream chat I
was on the fence this was amazing fun uh
I gotta calm down yeah so that's it I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is let's go hit 1 million much
love and see you soon we'll see you soon